i'm maria bartoromo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
liz clayman
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday july 21st 2021
i'm dave anthony there's a key vote in
the senate today
to move forward on a massive
infrastructure rebuild plan
what if it fails and the bill stalls
what
democrats could conceivably do is
weaponize this against republicans if
they vote against
ending the filibuster and say oh you see
we told you that they weren't interested
in bipartisanship to start with
i'm lisa brady the masked debate comes
roaring back
as the delta variant fuels a coveted
comeback
i do believe that if you're vaccinated
you should not
uh need to wear a mask and if you're
unvaccinated
you need you know you're making that
decision on your own um
you should wear a mask if you're
unvaccinated and i'm jimmy fella i've
got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
it's called a cloture vote and in the
senate
it's important the one scheduled today
would advance a trillion dollar
infrastructure
rebuild plan if you're serious about
getting a bipartisan bill done
there's no good reason not to support
the starting the process
now majority leader chuck schumer says
it's not like this is the final bill
there'll be no doubt many senators would
want to offer additional items from the
bipartisan framework or other issues
from transit to broadband to resiliency
and more schumer also wants democrats by
today
to unify behind another plan they call
human infrastructure worth three and a
half
trillion dollars which no republican
supports
this bill is going to be a massive tax
increase on business
and it's going to expand the size and
role of government democrats can pass it
using a budget process the gop
can't block but senator lindsey graham
tells fox
you're going to have inflation through
the roof and if they put
legalizing illegal immigrants in that
bill you're going to have a complete run
on the border
so i'd do anything i could to stop that
again that is separate
the vote today is just on that
bipartisan infrastructure plan
there's a filibuster against even
starting the bill and you need to get 60
votes
chad pergram is a fox news congressional
correspondent
the issue here is that you know
republicans have said since last week
and certainly over the weekend
the bill isn't quite done yet we've been
meeting we've been working around the
clock 24
7 deep into the night uh we're getting
there maybe just put this off a bit and
chuck schumer
heretofore has been unwilling to do so
well he has said
look we don't have to have all the final
details of the bill worked out we're
just
getting the ball rolling with this vote
essentially that's right
and it's not that big a surprise that
you have from time to time in the senate
uh votes on procedural matters when the
bill a bill isn't quite finished or
every
t isn't crossed and i dotted that's not
that rare that's the case that chuck
schumer has been making
although if you were to look at this
from the republican perspective you
could say
this is a way to undercut this
bipartisan effort we've worked for a
long time
democrats want to do their big 3.5
trillion dollar bill anyway
by themselves if they can all stick
together and that remains to be seen
and then what democrats could
conceivably do is weaponize this against
republicans if they vote against
ending the filibuster and say oh you see
we told you that they weren't interested
in bipartisanship to start with
and they couldn't even get 10
republicans to vote yes just to start
debate on the bill
that would be the argument and a lot of
people think that that's really what the
inner politics are going on here all
right
do they have 10 republicans in that they
do in that bipartisan group right
they do have they do right but again if
if you talk to bill cassidy
republican senator from uh louisiana
who's been very involved in this process
who says you know why
you know if you're you're setting
yourself up for program failures what he
said and i
threw this democratic argument at him
that maybe they were laying a trap for
the republicans and he said well a cynic
might say that he said i prefer not to
think that that's what's going on here
but it's just not him it's also susan
collins from maine
uh you know republican they're they're
all saying there's a way maybe
uh to hold the phone on this that three
and a half trillion dollar
separate plan where are we on that
well that bill isn't written either and
the reason i say
it remains to be seen whether or not
democrats can all get on the same page
you had the daca ruling by the judge a
couple of days ago
so democrats are now saying let's put
daca somehow in this or immigration
reform in this or voting
rights in this i mean you know this
thing is loaded up
with the term of art here on capitol
hill it's like a christmas tree and it's
only july
dave you know and so to get get that
balance just right
of the uh you know the democrats if
you're going to do this by yourself
get that vote mixture just right is very
very hard especially when you have
moderate democrats who generally are for
infrastructure
but they are skeptical of the price tag
they're worried about the actual
you know maybe putting in dental or
vision care for this which is going to
get
very expensive if you put that into
federal health programs you know which
is something they've talked about in
this bill
and you have pramila jayapal the chair
of the progressive caucus in the house
of representatives a congresswoman from
washington state
who says this is just a down payment we
want more nancy pelosi the speaker of
the house saying that the
the bill isn't maybe as green as she
would like it to be
so how you do this with a
you know a four or five vote margin in
the house and virtually no room for air
in the senate remains to be seen and
that's why we're probably going to be
here all the way through the fall
all right what is human infrastructure
as they've labeled the three and a half
trillion dollars what is this money
actually
gonna go to three and a half trillion
you talk about dental you talked about
vision for health what else is
they've talked about child care they've
talked about child care do they put
something related to immigration or daca
in this
uh you know you know that is all in the
eye of the beholder but
it's a lot of things that don't have to
do with roads and bridges it's the short
answer anything that deals with jobs and
health and so on and climate change what
what what about climate change
i know that's part of this something
they've talked about
is this climate core you know this is
another way to address that
uh what are the incentives in the bill
that deal with green energy green energy
tax credits or incentives for electric
vehicles or solar and wind power there's
a plethora of of
provisions in that that deal with you
know this this is not going to be
alexandria ocasio-cortez's green new
deal
but a lot of those thematics would
probably be in this bill certainly in
the
in the area of tax credits or maybe you
know moving government related programs
to
to be fueled by green energy or
something of that nature
we have the same names that we've talked
about before like joe manchin
kirsten cinema as potential democrats
who might be worried about the size of
the spending of that bill
what's the leadership doing about those
senators
well they're trying to figure out again
what that balance is joe manchin will
play a lot of
uh you know he a lot of cards are on the
table for joe manchin so that's pretty
important
and you know what we've seen from him
before is he usually holds out to the
last minute
and then gets something that he wants
again he's a moderate democrat
and gets something that's specific to
west virginia and so
everybody is kind of you know looking at
joe manchin but because the vote matrix
is so tight on this everybody is
essentially joe manchin
in both the house and senate because all
you need to do is hold out for your
thing whatever your thing is
and maybe that's going to influence
whether or not they have the right votes
to pass this bill in the house or the
senate
51 democratic lawmakers from texas
remain
in the washington dc area and several
now have covid
after fleeing the state to block a
republican election reform bill they
claim would suppress minority voting
i am an american and i want to vote
without somebody
infringing upon my rights and the rights
of my constituents
and i stand and fight him today but i
stand and fight for it
until i can't fight no more state rep
sinfonia thompson and the rest plan to
stay away
till the special session ends next month
but
republican texas governor greg abbott
who says the bill expands and secures
voting
says he'll just call another session so
gop state senator angela paxton tells
fox
their families are here their jobs are
here um
and this is their job i mean at a
certain point i think uh
the case will be made that they've
vacated their elective positions if they
don't come back
all that as democrat-led voting reform
remains stalled in congress republicans
blocked it as federal overreach
we're back to joe manchin again because
you had the texas democrats meeting
with him last week he said we're not
going to talk about changing the
filibuster the other provision because
they're like okay
we have to change the filibuster as well
in the senate you know lower the the
the threshold there from 60 votes to 51
votes like they do for
executive branch nominations and also
judges on the supreme court justices on
the supreme court
so the term of art you hear around
capitol hill
is a out the idea that you can
filibuster any other type of bill
the problem with that is if you crack
the door open on that dave
you're going to have every tom decker
harry lined up at chuck schumer's office
saying
oh but what about my bill mr leader what
about my bill can't we do a
carve out on that okay and you know i
could see where the pro
dc statehood or puerto rico statehood
people said well there's nothing more
important than preserving voting rights
or getting votes
for people who are unrepresented in
congress you know
again where does it stop you know that
is the classic
pandora's box right but the senate makes
that determination i keep hearing people
saying
hey president biden's got to get rid of
the filibuster but this is the senate's
decision right
right but that but but the question is
does he apply pressure
and this is where maybe let's bring this
full circle back to infrastructure
where maybe this bill blows up the
bipartisan bill because it does not get
60 votes to cut off a filibuster against
just getting onto the bill and
you know millimeter by millimeter
they're starting to say you see
joe manchin you see kirsten cinema this
is why we need to get rid of the
filibuster
because we can't get these things done
and maybe
over time those issues start to ripen
the other thing that happens
is that some people make the point that
if you do get rid of the filibuster and
you do pass these things which remains
to be seen just if you were to get rid
of the filibuster
and you have to have people like joe
manchin and kirsten cinema willing
to get rid of the filibuster and
heretofore they are not then
when the republicans get control of the
senate whenever that is be it
january of 2023 or down the road they
will undo
all of these things because why
democrats
then in the minority cannot filibuster
them
and so caveat emptor be careful of what
you ask
yeah but i mean if you can get the law
changed now you can worry about that
later right
well that is the obama care approach to
legislating
they passed that in 2009 and 2010
republicans have fought hammer and tong
for 12 years to get that off the books
have never been successful and obamacare
remains the law of the land you know uh
richard neo's the chair of the ways and
means committee and there's been a lot
of talk lately about this child tax
credit
uh that they've put on the books here
and maybe making it permanent it's just
up for a short period of time there is a
sunset to it
and neil said in relation to that he
said you know it's a lot easier
to get something on than once it's on
the books to take it off
so maybe that's the democrats approach
you know you get it on the books
whatever it is and as you say live to
fight another day
if the vote on wednesday doesn't get
to 60 and they can't get going will they
try again
or will this be something that democrats
use to make the case
that they have to go on their own for
everything infrastructure
they certainly could i i mean you got to
remember there's an awful lot of kabuki
theater going on right now in shadow
boxing
everybody's kind of daring one another
you know
and chuck schumer in addition to maybe
saying oh i can turn this around on the
republicans and say you're not
willing to be bipartisan whereas
republicans probably said the same thing
to chuck schumer
is that he knows that infrastructure
the brick and mortar infrastructure you
know girders and bridges and things
that's pretty popular with the public
and therefore
if they vote against that that is a
really tough vote for them to take
and our friends at the democratic
senatorial campaign committee the dscc
they're sitting about a block and a half
from the capitol they're in charge of
getting democrats elected to the senate
they're going to document that roll call
vote on wednesday
and they're going to turn it around and
weaponize it against
these republicans who vote no on that
procedural vote and say can you believe
that they voted against this and you can
see the ad that's running in october
you know 2022 right now with the erie
music and you see the little
script at the bottom of the screen that
says that's going to be that roll call
vote because they will turn it against
those republicans but nothing on
infrastructure
either one of these bills will pass
anytime soon
in final version right no we're probably
at
on a fast track we're probably at least
two to three weeks away
and on a more moderate track probably
sometime in august as i always say
beware the ides of august august is the
craziest month always on capitol hill
chad pergram fox news congressional
correspondent always good to talk to you
thanks chad
[Music]
likewise
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
president biden is beating a drum the
safest thing to do
is to get vaccinated get vaccinated
also urging americans to stay vigilant
amid another coveted search
thanks largely to the delta variant
valkova 19 cases are
rising virtually all of the cova death
virtually
all of the cova deaths and
hospitalizations are from unvaccinated
people
on tuesday several breakthrough
infections were confirmed among
fully vaccinated staff both at the white
house and on capitol hill
including a senior aide to house speaker
nancy pelosi but the capital attending
physician
is not bringing back a mask mandate
neither is the cdc
still saying fully vaccinated people
don't need to wear masks
although federal health officials also
say local rules should be followed and
those
vary widely raising many questions again
texas governor greg abbott tells fox
news with regard to schools in
particular
listen i've made it very clear this is
an issue of parental
choice and will not be an issue of
mandates this after the american academy
of pediatrics recommended
universal masking in schools for
everyone over age two
like the white house cdc director
rachelle malenski is emphasizing the
effectiveness of vaccines
as protection from the worst of covet
even though there's still a small chance
of getting it
the best way to prevent the spread of
covet 19
variants is to prevent the spread of
disease and vaccination is the most
powerful tool we have
dr balenski told a senate panel on
tuesday that in just the past few weeks
the delta variant has gone from an
estimated half of genetically sequenced
coveted cases in the u.s
to more than 80 percent of the cases i
am not surprised by the breakthrough
cases
doctor and retired admiral brett jorah
was an assistant health secretary under
president trump
we know that the vaccines are highly
effective
well over 90 percent in fact a study was
just published
two days ago among uh patients in the
veterans administration here
in the united states and you know a lot
of the veterans tend to be in poor
health but their
vaccine effectiveness was 97
you know seven days after the second
shot so um
i'm not surprised by the breakthrough
just because you do the percentages
there's always going to be a few percent
of individuals
that will get sick despite the high
protection but we still
see enormous protection against
hospitalization and death so i
i think we expected this and as more and
more people get vaccinated
uh it's going to be more likely that the
people who are in the hospital
are vaccinated just because of the
numbers well the spread of the delta
variant in particular has certainly
brought
the mask controversy roaring back again
we have la county that's gone back to
mandating them
indoors for everyone and former surgeon
general dr jerome adams who
you worked with on the trump white house
kova team is saying the cdc
should update its mass guidance at least
in areas with
rising numbers do you agree does it
really depend on where you are and what
the risk is
in that place so i think i have a
different take on that
um i still believe that the cdc guidance
is correct
in that if you are fully vaccinated you
do not need to wear a mask
in public indoors or outdoors i believe
that's correct
guidance based on the science i also
believe it is correct
that if you are not vaccinated you
really should wear a mask
because it will provide some protection
to you
and certainly protection against you
spreading the virus to other people the
delta variant
is very infectious it's probably
no more dangerous than the normal uh
coronavirus that we've all been
working with for the past 15 months but
it is clearly more
infectious in terms of local mass
mandates
um you know the cdc and the
administration said it's up to the
localities and
and it is um i find that very strange
you know when we were in the trump
administration
uh we were chastised every day for not
having national mandates and forcing
people to do x y or z
but you see that the byte administration
is doing the same thing because public
health is really a state and local
kind of uh event that should be done
locally
that being said uh i don't think mass
mandates
are the appropriate way to go um i do
believe
that if you're vaccinated you should not
uh need to wear a mask
and if you're unvaccinated you need you
know you're making that decision
on your own um you should wear a mask if
you're unvaccinated
and the third component that seems to
have disappeared
completely is the idea of testing um i
was the testing czar
and there was not a day in the white
house that the administration did not
get beaten up because everyone wanted
more testing and again
we developed hundreds of millions of
tests per month
but you're not hearing anything about
testing if i were the biden
administration in these areas of
outbreak
i would be sending home tests to
everyone there so they could test
themselves this is a drop in the bucket
in terms of money
and can provide a lot of protection what
about
a place like a school building where
you have people of different ages some
who are not eligible for vaccines yet
in very close quarters and i ask this
because you've got the american academy
of pediatrics now recommending
universal masking in schools for this
fall for children as young as two
why not be that cautious in a setting
like that
i think for children 12 or over who've
been vaccinated
the cdc is correct there is no need
for a child who's been vaccinated to
even contemplate
wearing a mask because they are
protected
highly protected given their
young immune systems and robust
responses so i think the aap is wrong
if you're vaccinated you shouldn't wear
a mask i personally have
issues with the data on children under
five years of age
even it's very strange the aap cites
uh how good the world health
organization and some of the un
organizations and we need to follow them
because that shows how kids could be
safe but in the
exact material that the aap cites it
basically says do not wear a mask if
you're under five
that it will interfere with their social
and develop social skills and
development
and will cause more harm than good and
for children 6 to 11
you have to really be careful and only
use it in select circumstances
so you know this is not an obvious issue
to me under 5 there's no data
that masks actually help and we know
that the risks to children are
incredibly incredibly small
for six to eleven i you know i think
it's sort of
up to the individual school districts in
understanding what the spread is like
but i think there needs to be an
affirmative reason to wear a mask
as opposed to just doing it because it
seems like the right thing to do without
data
and i'll just make one point if you look
at
school outbreaks the majority of them
were caused by
teachers coming into the school and
spreading it to other staff
it's not caused by children coming in
and spreading it to other children
or to teachers so if anything um we need
to make sure
all our teachers are vaccinated and if
they choose not to get vaccinated
i think that needs to be looked at
pretty hard in terms of their risk of
spreading the disease to children
the white house has blamed at least some
of the vaccine
hesitancy on covet and vaccine
misinformation i know you don't
necessarily agree
that that's the problem but but why not
and
and what is the problem so i i have real
concerns vaccine misinformation has been
out there for a long time and it's
something
i tried to deal with as the assistant
secretary for health and the head of the
national vaccine program
actually um so it is it is real
i i put these into a couple of
categories we we know that there are
russian and chinese misinformation
campaigns
that are spread over the internet in
order to create discontent
within the united states we know who
those people are and where they come
from
and we need to do everything possible to
eliminate them from the web
but i do have concerns about the us
government
telling private companies what is
correct and what is
incorrect information i do believe that
censorship that's sort of the definition
of violation of rights to free speech by
the government
and i sign up for justice brandeis that
is
the remedy here is more speech and not
enforced silence while the u.s and other
parts of the world
deal with kovid's latest stand the
question of how it all started
remains unanswered with more attention
now on the lab
that was studying these types of viruses
in wuhan china
which became the epicenter of the
pandemic dr
fauci knowing that it is a crime to lie
to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11 where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wuhan at the senate hearing on
tuesday kentucky republican senator and
dr rand paul
grilled dr anthony fauci once again
about funding from the national
institutes of health
and dr fauci pushed back harder this
time you increased his responsibility to
humans right
you're saying that's not gain a function
yeah that is correct and and
senator paul you do not know what you
are talking about
though the nih director dr francis
collins has offered more
nuanced answers before acknowledging
it's possible funding could have been
used
that way without authorization but
should that question be part of the
search for answers
about kovitt so i think they're related
but they're two separate questions
one is what is the origin and you know
i've testified and i've said publicly
that i think the
evidence right now is uh
is pointing to a lab leak from the wuhan
institute of virology
and there's so many lines of evidence
both the lack of
of this virus being in nature
and nothing being close to it as well as
all the types of research that was going
on there
at wuhanus due to virology the
intelligence reports showing lab workers
becoming sick
the fact that it was perfectly or near
perfectly
transmittable to humans from day one
viruses that develop in nature
and come from animals don't do that and
i think that was compelling
for dr redfield and his expert opinion
that it became from the lab so
that's the origin issue the second issue
was whether
the nih funded the research um and
whether they funded the research
directly or indirectly nih money was
going to the wuhan institute of virology
it was going through the eco health
alliance it wasn't a large amount of
money
but it was there but i do think it's a
tip of the iceberg problem
how much money from the nih is funding
laboratories that engage in potentially
dangerous research um around the world
we need to know that what is the review
process
or gain of function or what i would call
gain of opportunity research
i think these types of questions are
certainly related to origins
but um whether or not the nih funded the
research
that led to this pandemic
does not detract from the overall
question
about how do we monitor and how do we
control
and provide accountability for
potentially dangerous research
particularly in foreign countries i am
much less concerned about the united
states and the research infrastructure
here
because we're transparent there are
multiple levels of controls
people have freedom to speak but in a
repressive regime like china you really
don't know what's going on there
and i do believe scientists are
threatened with their lives or their
freedom
in order to toe the party line so we
really need
new levels of accountability and control
and i encourage
uh in a bipartisan fashion that congress
investigates this
and sets up standards for the future
admiral brett jorah as
always we thank you very very much for
your time
it's always a pleasure to be on and uh
again i think
uh your show does a great service
to america by letting us explore the
issues a little more
in depth so that people can get the
right information
and make good decisions for themselves
and their family so i truly thank you
for your interest in your always great
questions
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fella
what's on your mind so prince harry
announced that he's releasing a memoir
about leaving the royal family
if this matters to you doctors urge you
to seek help immediately
i mean seriously haven't we heard enough
from this whiny
woe is me no nothing sure the guy might
have been a member of the royals but he
was like 12th in line to the crown
the only way harry gets to be the king
is if he plays a game of chess
and that's assuming he could stop being
a pawn for his fame hungry wife
the ex-prince of bel-air is reportedly
making 20 million bucks which works out
to a dollar for every time he and megan
claim they just wanted their privacy
because i know when i want to be left
alone i start a podcast do a netflix
series
sit down for an oprah interview and then
write a book about the whole thing
seriously you two don't need a book deal
you need a mirror earth to harry and
megan
nobody wants to hear how hard life is as
a member of the royal family
because it's still way easier than
everyone else's but these two bozos keep
playing the victim card because on some
level they actually feel sorry for
themselves
yeah harry and megan might be the
biggest frauds of all time but at this
point they're only fooling themselves
i'm jimmy thaler
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon bream host of fox news at
night and author of the new book
women of the bible speak the wisdom of
16 women and their lessons for today
subscribe now on apple podcast spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes